der haut die diesjährigen filmtage in
solothurn gleich eröffnen darf
ohne in hektik zu verfallen geht die
newcomerin ihrer feuertaufe entgegen der
premiere in solothurn sind es gar die
ersten schritte einer großen regie
laufbahn claudia lorenz weder bereit
dafür
ihr drama unter der haut erzählt vom
überraschenden coming out des dreifachen
familienvaters nach 18 jahren ehe
am premieren ort der reithalle laufen
die vorbereitungen auf hochtouren
vieles ist noch nicht an seinem platz
der nackte raum weckt assoziationen der
familie claudia lorenz fängt den zauber
ende in jedem anfang steckt doch das
neue macht auch angst zwingt zur
konfrontation mit dem unbekannten
im moment wo sich homosexuelle person
outet das kombinat für die person ist
selber betroffen sondern auch das umfeld
was sich renate muss mit auto oder wie
muss mit dem auseinandersetzen und den
fall dass mami es super mit den
selbstzweifeln der verlassenen frau und
war lorenz bei den recherchen besonders
interessiert mit größten einzelmärkten
manchmal genügen ein paar klicks und das
vertrauen in das vertraute zu verlieren
claudia lorenz hat ein kammerspiel
inszeniert weil sie sich für das
interessiert was räumlich und seelisch
im innern der betroffenen familie
geschieht
die auswirkung des coming out nicht
dessen ursachen stehen im vordergrund
dass das möglich ist
das blieb dem film unbeantwortet und das
bleibt unbeantwortet aus dem grund dass
sie wirklich glaubt dass sexualität und
zwar die eigene claudia vom partner oder
der partnerin eigentlich ihre sands mit
etwas salat oder nicht kleiner land
unter der haut ist eine feine studie
über die unergründlichkeit der liebe
zwar zahlen schon schade wenn das buch
macht den zwei kritische worte nicht
privat will er spielt ganz intimer
ordner mich in der familie
und gleich eine sehr klare
gesellschaftspolitische dimension will
so musste magath wo immer noch recht
tabu ist und zog sie als privater durch
ruß politische dimension nicht jeder
moment in unter der haut wirkt
authentisch doch das gesamtbild stimmt
und lässt eine glänzende zukunft erahnen
ein vielversprechender neubeginn für die
talentierte regisseurin und ihre
filmfiguren
von lionel baier geht es auch um
homosexuelle